we talked about twitter yeah big story
on the joe rogan podcast
he is interviewing mark zuckerberg no
[ __ ]
no [ __ ] he did it already uh i'm
laughing because
i'm tempted to respond in kind my father
hated it when i cursed
hated it and i used to do it much more
freely than i do right now yeah um once
in a while we went off camera
my father used to wince when i when i
would curse and so i worked on it and
now i've got to the point where i don't
do it anymore now you're going no
wait he did it already they did the
interviewer okay did the interview
already okay very long interview as you
know he's linked the link the interview
was kind of like shocked yeah
and he of course asked mark zuckerberg
about the hunter biden laptop story
which which uh which uh facebook and
twitter both suppress twitter uh didn't
even retweet the story on the new york
post shut down the new york post's
ability to do it and facebook also
altered the algorithm so that far fewer
people saw it than otherwise would have
yeah and zuckerberg says and i'm
paraphrasing this is very important how
he phrased it he said
some people from the fbi
came to us
or came to some members of my team
and said
that there's going to be some
wow some stories that are going to be
dropping pretty soon
and it is likely going to be russian
disinformation
and we want to give you a heads up
they did not specifically say there's
going to be a story about hunter by
laptop
but within days of the fbi coming to
zuckerberg's people zuckerberg said that
the laptop story dropped
we assumed again i'm paraphrasing we
connected the
warning to the story and that's why we
suppressed it
uh rogan followed up by asking did they
specifically talk about the hundred
biden story he didn't say it quite that
way he didn't say quite that well
frankly he should have i was critical of
the interview and i'll tell you why in a
second yeah
zuckerberg said no but they told us
there's going to be russian
disinformation as there was in 2016 says
the fbi and we should be wary of that
and so when the hunter biden story broke
i thought that's what the fbi was
talking about referring to so that's why
we suppressed the story
wow and he admitted he zuckerberg
admitted that they alter the algorithm
so that it didn't get the name same kind
of coverage that otherwise would have
and and uh and use the word meaningful
meaning the percentage of people who did
not see it was meaningful
so first let's so so just getting back
to you about being a libertarian yeah
it's one thing for a private company to
make that decision it's another thing
for the government to essentially
warn you knowing full well that you're
going to take the warning seriously and
so it makes it almost state action now
right so at that level so in essence
what you have is the government
outsourcing the tyranny the government
is basically saying here it's a threat
if they're calling facebook there is
some level of a threat involved there's
some stuff coming down the pike that if
you promote
you might have some other problems we
might want to audit you or all sorts of
stuff so so that's where they are
outsourcing the tyranny they're not
stepping on the first amendment directly
well this is sort of like remember when
saki said over what was it was it last
summer when saki said that the
government flags certain posts for us
well
uh or uh you know we flag certain posts
for for facebook i should say it's like
this has been happening for a long time
so
when did this happen this zuckerberg
interview is this last couple days last
last ten days maybe last 10 days so are
people
hopefully realizing what's going on here
like
again
any of our robots the npc's our side
meaning the non-woke side is reacting
exactly as you as you have just done
surprised
but the others aren't saying a whole lot
uh because there was a study that was
done by a media research group and found
that 16 percent of joe biden voters say
had they known about the hunter biden
laptop story they would not have voted
for biden so it clearly altered the
election but something altered the
election even bigger and one of the
reasons i was critical of joe rogan's
interview is he didn't bring this up
you know about the 419 and a half
million dollars that zuckerberg spent of
his own yeah zuckerberg to bring out uh
democratic turnout uh molly hemingway
wrote a book about it called rigged i'm
sure you talked i saw her right before
uh right before i went up right i
interviewed her and um
uh citizens united did a documentary
about it still online you can watch it
for 40 minutes we talked about how
zuckerberg strategically went to
election officials in places where there
were a lot of democratic votes
cleveland detroit atlanta
philadelphia to gin up democrat turnout
now the idea was that he was being a
good government guy
and some money was spent for republican
turnout as well but like maybe 10
percent and 99 for democrats so clearly
he did it to tip the scale in favor of
democrats
rogan did not mention it
in a two-hour interview did not raise it
that's interesting how do you do that
how do you how do you not have mark
zuckerberg in front of you yeah and not
bring up it's like
am i talking to the wright brothers not
not missing airplanes or him before not
using cars right or o.j simpson not
mentioning he killed two people
i cut took that door at least took a
ride in the broncos i took it like you
took that in a dark place didn't die but
but how do you not ask him about the 419
million dollars of your own money that
you spent
on the election in 2020 how do you do it
he didn't ask it i'm going to go back
and watch it for sure the only thing
that i can say slightly in rogan's
defense on this which just as an
interviewer and you know this too
sometimes over the course of an
interview you're doing something and
especially if it's live and you don't
edit that you want to get back to
something and it just doesn't present
itself that's not really like a
full-throated um excuse or something
because he should have hit on that but
but putting that aside you know what's
interesting about this is remember jack
dorsey from twitter
once the new york times said that the
hunter biden laptop was real jack dorsey
basically who doesn't work at twitter
anymore so when he was running it he did
all the bad [ __ ] now he doesn't a pardon
my french yeah he did all the bad stuff
he said we shouldn't uh but but now that
he doesn't run it anymore he says we
shouldn't have done it now
years after the election result that
zuckerberg wanted now he can kind of
sort of admit there was government
pressure to do something
and it's like how many times will we
continue to play monopoly with a bunch
of people who own all the hotels on park
avenue who we know are rigging the game
right
that's the question joe rogan also
getting back to him for a second
he had a guest on i think of him in
minute and
they were talking about
covet shutting everything down and how
the
organization cdc mandated this and the
other
and now we're finding out that the
lockdown bad idea finding out that uh
regular immunity natural immunity is
stronger uh finding out that the
vaccines for young people were probably
pointless because young people don't get
it
and rogan said when asked what's oh he's
talking to aaron rodgers the quarterback
of the quarterback of the packers
and roger says what's the answer and uh
rogan said vote republican oh he did so
he's really getting there so he's ready
his red pilling has been really nice
because it's taken him a while let's not
forget this this guy was a you know he
was very conflicted about his views i
think in a lot of ways and everyone is
to some extent when you're waking up
because the guy was a bernie supporter
who then left california for tax
purposes so it's like you got to piece
these things together man you can say
i'm a nice bernie supporter socialist
and i like all this stuff i don't pay
taxes but i don't want to pay taxes so
i'm moving to texas
so his you know this is this is sort of
similar to right before i left he said
that he was going to vote for desantis
so that's great because he he's got real
influence and if you think about it
there's not a lot of people that could
move politically right you got your
people that are hardcore republicans
let's say and hardcore democrats i think
the sliver of people that could move are
the disaffected libs it is the the bill
maher rogenesque
it's those libs that are just like a
couple years maybe behind where i was
that those are the ones that can still
be shifted let's say so that that's
great to hear
um speaking of of rogers he was very
critical of the nfl
and he called him stooges
for mandating all of this uh
all these rules and regulations good um
joke of this novak djokovic uh is not
going to be playing in this year's u.s
open because he refuses to get
vaccinated they're still still doing
that now you can go and watch the us
open not being vaccinated and if you're
born in america and have not been
vaccinated you can play but because he
is a foreigner and because the cdc
requires anybody coming in from out of
the country to be vaccinated he cannot
play in the u.s open is that right that
that's still a thing
so right now if you were to come to the
united states
on vacation you have to be back i think
so
jeez i think so
the vaccine which uh will stop and or
prevent the spread of kovid until it
doesn't